darius what's up man how are you welcome
back
oh my god that was so entertaining
what's up dude how you doing i missed
you i i missed you too how was your trip
dude it was fantastic uh everyone needs
to go to paris and spend at least a week
there before they die um and by the way
i've been on that same flight uh tokyo
or jfk to narita and then down to
singapore it is brutal
it it is uh considered one of the
longest flights in the world and uh
i have this theory that once you're on a
plane for 11 hours 11 hours is the
breaking point you're just like this
sucks like
11 hours 30 minutes or 18 hours is all
the same at that point you've seen my
big ass i mean like that 11 hours is
like six hours to me
i love it i love it all right let's uh
jump in maybe the first place we could
start is jamie dimon i think it was
yesterday before uh he came out and he
said that he believes there's an
economic hurricane on the horizon and he
basically said look nobody knows how big
it'll be how bad it'll be or how long
it'll last we're going to be super
conservative with our balance sheet uh
and i suggest you know basically
everyone else follow the same thing so
it wasn't some like big prediction uh
but it definitely was like hey you guys
should be paying attention to what's
coming down the pipe and we're going to
be more conservative than we have in the
past because we want to be able to
withstand it what's your general
reaction from the ceo of one of the
largest banks in the world talking like
this uh so openly is that something that
we should read into or should we just
expect them to do this so i'll start by
saying the great great starting point i
i'll start by saying
these guys are only as good as their
models and their forecasters and the
people who work for them that forecast
the economy i'm not making any
representations about how good the jp
morgan economist team is um all i'm
saying is you shouldn't take their words
uh more than their words they're worth
their worth they're just it's just the
guy who has a view in the world that we
have a view in the world uh but i do
agree with this view in the world we are
heading to uh something that could look
like a hurricane now whether it's a
category two or a category five is yet
to be determined but it's at least going
to be a hurricane and right now we are
still on the beach in brighton sunny
conditions and so in our opinion um i
think jamie dimon is appropriate uh he's
being a good steward of capital and
trying to help investors prepare for
that so you've got a chart that kind of
leads into this um it's the financial
conditions remain uncomfortably loose
which is very different story than what
i think we're hearing in the uh kind of
public narrative right everyone's
talking about quantitative tightening
they've uh started to conduct that
they're raising interest rates there's
been tough talk since like november of
last year uh by the federal reserve but
this chart's telling a little bit of a
different story so explain kind of what
this is uh what this is showing us and
like why why is the data showing us
something different than maybe the
public narrative
yeah no 100 man so this this is a really
important chart and i want everyone to
sort of take some time to kind of
understand this the red line just shows
the goldman sachs financial conditions
index uh basically how the how to
interpret the chart is when it's low
that means combination conditions are
loose they're you know very
accommodative and when the index is high
is a high value the means comanche is
very tight we've seen a decent
tightening off the lows in the red line
but if you look at it on a historical
basis i mean we're basically about as
loose as we were at the peak of the
dot-com bubble in terms of you know so
if you think about this in terms of the
fed's inflation fighting uh directive
they haven't really done anything to get
growth to slow down enough to cause
inflation to slow down which tells you
that hey as an investor here we might
have you know seen some pretty
significant declines off the highs and
you know crypto bitcoin et cetera but
they could get a lot worse if the fed is
going to be successful in achieving its
inflation objective
so when you start to think about this
there's
this whole idea of quantitative
tightening and really over the last i
don't know 13 15 years whatever you want
to kind of count
there's been a very loose monetary
policy they at one point did try to
conduct quantitative tightening it
didn't go so hot they basically waved
the white flag very quickly they went
back to lose monetary policy explain to
people in you know kind of one or two
sentences like when you think of
quantitative tightening what should they
be paying attention to or like what are
the important things to watch as they
start to conduct this
oh well i mean number one i mean what's
the level of volatility both implied and
realized in financial markets because
what happens when the fed does it starts
to shrink its balance sheet we all
understand that qe is positive for
markets but the reason is positive for
markets is mostly due to a substitution
effect we're taking
safe securities out of the marketplace
and leaving investors uh you know
whether they be
asset managers you know retail investors
ultimately through mutual funds et
cetera with a bunch of cash that's
burning a hole in their pocket and that
needs to go to work if they're trying to
generate a legitimate return you know a
real return and so the content of
tightening effectively works in reverse
the fed is now creating a hole on the on
the on the sort of the risk-free end of
that spectrum and now a lot of the money
has to rush from the uh the further out
on the risk curve to capitalize the us
government and it says you're creating
this sort of vacuum the sucking effect
on that the further outs on the wrist
curve so um you know when you said
quantitative tightening they tried it
and then they waved the white flag
you're absolutely right and the scary
part about this particular time around
is that not only are they going to do
quantitative tightening into a global
growth slow down a u.s growth slow down
but more importantly they're going to
try to get to a double from the previous
pace of quantitative tiding we've never
seen this before we've never seen the
fed hiking interest rates 50 bips at a
time doing 50 to 100 billion dollars of
quantitative tightening at a time as
they will be in a few months and so i
think it's a real so it's a science
experiment to say the least
when you think of that
if they've never done this before at the
speed severity you know kind of
simultaneous actions the whole thing
should we throw out all historical
analysis uh because this is a new
environment and something that we
haven't seen before or do you think
history can still serve as a great guide
uh as we evaluate what could happen in
the future
yeah no 100 you don't want to throw out
historical analysis and analogs but what
you do want to understand is that
everything financial markets operate
from a rate of change perspective and
particularly rate of change relative to
expectations and so you know when you
look at the world through that sort of
you know frac that that that very
quantitative lens rate of change what's
happening at the margin what's changing
at the margins you then can bring in the
historical analogs that help you
identify
hey you know the fed might be shrinking
its balance sheet with bigger numbers
now but on a relative basis to what the
balance sheet was this is you know it's
called a one sigma move uh lower or two
sigma move lower so you can normalize
things and help you create more
scientific and more thoughtful analogs
using historical data and the reality is
when you're talking about the kind of
gross slowdown that our model is
projecting at the same time you have a
quantitative tightening episode you're
talking about anything on the order of
20 to 30 percent annualized declines in
s p
40 to 50 annualized declines in high
beta stocks and and 60 i utilize
declines in something like bitcoin um
this is a really negative a macro
environment from a flows perspective um
so all bets are off if you think about
uh you know trying to buy the dip here
at which a lot of investors have done
so they continued to talk about very
aggressive interest rate um increases uh
quantitative tightening all the stuff
we're talking about the market at one
point was pricing in 10 rate hikes 300
basis uh 300 basis point
interest rate uh you've got some data
that says we might not get there which i
think uh is becoming more and more
obvious uh talk to us about this data
and then what do you think is gonna
happen
so uh actually fill up that chart the
second chart usc you are yeah uh not
this one the other one uh usd eur and uh
gpus so we're probably not gonna get
there but we don't have to get there the
market just has to get there for them
and what i mean by this is uh these
charts show um the overnight index uh
uh for you know basically money market
rates that are that are trying to price
in the fifth fund's rate on future uh
time uh time horizon so you're looking
on a one year four basis the market's
about somewhere around three point two
percent which is obviously significantly
higher than what the current funds rate
expectation is that number had peaked in
early may and was really starting to
flag and particularly as we started to
get some leaking commentary out of
federal reserve officials that they
might actually consider a pause in
september you know you know
with the expectation that obviously
inflation would be starting to behave
and get under control by then well
in terms of our analysis we're we're not
seeing anything in the inflation data
that says it has to be under control by
september i mean that in the best case
scenario we have core pce on a
three-month annualized basis at just shy
of three percent um in the month of uh
in the month of september data that'll
be reported in late october and so this
concept that they're going to be able to
pause in september really sort of has to
lean on some very polyanish forecast for
inflation that somehow magically just
gets under control without the fed ever
taking financial conditions into
restrictive territory which in our
opinion is very aggressive
all right and then you've got a third uh
graph here that says the global downturn
is not adequately priced in which is
crazy to think about given the asset
price sell-off etc uh what is this
telling us
yeah no so this chart is uh super
important the blue line is sort of a
proxy for global growth that's the world
oecd composite leading index time series
um the the red line shows the s p 500
high beta to low beta ratio uh so that's
the high beta stocks relative to low
beta stocks and historically so in in
basically throughout you know our
duration of our careers uh pump um we've
had three of these sort of global growth
slowdowns you know kind of you know
let's call it 2010 to 2012 you know 2015
16 and then obviously 2018 due 2020. um
you know these are non-recessionary
slowdowns i don't really count the the
lockdown as a recession these are
non-recessionary slowdowns and this s p
500 high beta lobeta ratio uh again high
beta stocks both the low beta stocks
declined 35 to 40 in each of these three
instances we're only down about you know
let's call it 18 19 now which suggests
that even if we if we slow and do not go
into recession we're still only about
halfway done in terms of the amount of
pain that we're likely to experience in
financial markets and obviously if we go
into a recession all bets are off you
look at the far left um uh instance uh
observation there down sixty percent i
mean i'm not anticipating global
financial crisis but obviously there's
you know something that looks more like
the 2000 to 2002 unwind the dot-com
bubble which has been our core analog um
is something that is very much on the on
the tape in play
got it and then when you start to think
about uh these asset prices obviously uh
we continue to watch what i'm going to
call a change in psychology among market
participants so investors waking up
saying hey you know things are changing
now we're starting to see founders of
businesses or the executives of
businesses doing the same thing and it
seems like there's maybe like a chain
reaction public markets obviously they
woke up in q1 uh because they saw the
stock prices falling there was a ton of
uh talk about it then we started to see
like the growth uh stocks in the private
market they started to feel it because
there were people pointing and saying
hey well your public comps those
multiples just compressed you now have a
different valuation even if your
business is still growing you've got
great cash whatever and now you're
almost even seeing it trickle into like
maybe like series a series b private
market stuff like how do you think about
the relationships across even just in
equities public and private markets and
like this like chain reaction of the
psychological um evolution that occurs
yeah this is that's one of the best
questions i've gotten all year so thank
you for doing that yeah i mean you're
one of the best so i mean it's all good
uh um so
there's a couple things i want to unpack
there
chain reaction is very important phrase
in that in that question because i think
what we
miss as investors we sort of think about
things like recession or recovery or in
reality is it's not just this one
monolithic thing the economy is not this
one monolithic thing you know by
threshold for what i can bear from a
financial debt service perspective is
very different than your threshold is
very different than the thresholds of
people who are watching us live right
now and so the reality is this concept
that hey look when at series 8 when xyz
fund takes marks on this thing they
might not even be taking their marks at
the same time as other funds take their
marks there's a legitimate chain
reaction and right now we're in a
reflexive part of the cycle we're in a
reflexive down cycle so that when these
things start to happen
they're going to send signals and
triggers to other funds like right like
if you're a founder uh you know you
you're done well in a company you you
baby raise some uh some decent commands
you're probably not rushing out to buy
dips in in you know in small private
enterprises right now so that
segment of the financing economy really
slows down obviously we've seen i think
want to say it's been on uh 270 to 200 i
was reading this on bloomberg this
morning a deal of debt financing deals
that have been just postponed this year
year to date you know so we're really
starting to see a real slowdown in
backup and financing activity in the
economy and that really matters and the
reason it really matters
is because we're obviously a very
indebted nation uh with the exception of
household debt we're seeing a very
aggressive rise in corporate credit and
corporate debt outstanding in public
debt outstanding and it's a very
financialized economy on top of that i
mean 70
of all of our of private non-financial
sector credit uh in the u.s economy is
is is is intermediate by non-bank
financial participants which means all
these interest rates the rise in in
corporate borrowing costs the rise in
mortgage rates the rise in real interest
rates all this stuff really matters in
terms of slowing the rate of activity
one of the things i keep coming back to
is this idea that uh global debt to gdp
is like 130 percent or i'm sorry it's
like 350 percent
the us is 130 give or take uh and so
when you start to do this like gdp
growth's got to be double digits right
to basically get on the other side of
this um is that possible like is it
possible to literally grow our way out
of the global debt to gdp ratios
no absolutely not i mean
the reason we grow is because of the add
new debt like yeah sure yeah actually no
let me say that there could be some
massive and this is what kathy wood is
betting on obviously some massive change
in technology that ushers in a wave of
productivity that allows us to be
substantially more productive uh with
the limited resources that we have and i
would say uh limited and declining
resources i mean you you think about the
kind of the aging of the baby boomer
population and you know this the size of
that relative to the gen z population
we're going to have a reduction in our
workforce over the long term at least
over the next kind of 10 12 years or so
so that's going to be an issue in terms
of trying to create gdp right we're
running out we already ran out of land
we're running out of workers so we've
got to find something some technology
that creates a lot more productivity and
may or may not come
certainly is not going to come you know
in terms of the time horizon that we
want to manage risk on as it relates to
the downside of this market cycle
yeah it's um it's just fascinating kind
of think about the idea that like we
have to keep playing this game and so
when you think about uh fiat currencies
you know somebody like brent johnson uh
who he recently had on was talking about
his milkshake theory and uh we talked
him in 2020 talked to him again uh this
year and
in recent weeks he looks pretty smart
dollar strengthened again you know
relatively against other fiat currencies
like how do you see the currency markets
playing out uh with all the fiats on a
relative basis
you know it's uh it's weird i think
we're at a very interesting point in the
in the milkshake shout out to brent
because he's been now he's absolutely
nailed that call you know what one thing
i think is um particularly unique in
this second circumstance is that during
the covet recovery
the u.s economy was aggressively
capitalized by the rest of the world and
as a function of that we significantly
outperformed the rest of the world and
not just as a function of that we
obviously had better vaccines we had
better reopening um at least you know
places like miami never really shut down
i mean you can go there in april 2020
and wouldn't know there was a pandemic
but i digress uh but so we we had a
substantial outperformance in our
economy and as a function of that
investors all around the world were
happy to just throw money in our markets
whether it be in apple stock you know
google stock you know amazon tesla et
cetera et cetera so much so that you
know we've seen about six to seven
trillion dollars over the last couple of
years enter the u.s economy from a
capital inflows perspective if you look
at the change our net international
investment position well that's not to
say that that all has to come out over
the next two years but it does seem to
suggest that hey
if the us just comes back to earth and
we are we're arguing in our research
we're not going to just go back to earth
we're going to go to a below trend
growth state by the end of this sort of
projection period or our next 12 month
projection period
if we go to a below trend growth state
what's the reasoning for about being you
know overly allocated overweight u.s
assets particularly us risk assets
relative to the rest of the world and i
would posit that that reason
significantly goes away and this is
exactly what happened in the unwind of
the tech bubble it wasn't just that the
fed was too easy in response to the
asian financial crisis and long-term
capital management that caused the the
nasdaq to go up it was the fact that the
world was blowing up and every sovereign
wealth fund and every asset allocator
and every you know global asset manager
was keen to dump money in our markets
because we have a legitimate growth
cycle and a significant outperformance
and growth back then in the late 90s and
it was no different than it was in this
cove recovery period and now that uh
starting to unwind at the margin so to
answer your question is a very
long-winded answer i apologize for this
i'm not so sure that the dollar is
likely to continue heading higher even
though the fed is um is going to
continue to remove liquidity now the
dollar may again i'm not saying the
dollar is peaked yet but i think if you
look at on a six month and nine month 12
month four basis i could easily see a
scenario where the nasdaq's down i don't
know 20 to 30 percent from here and the
dollar's down 5-10 percent versus pure
currencies
so when you think about kind of what the
fed can do uh
do you have a thought process
on the quantitative tightening like
is it sometimes it's not good
to break something that's yeah that's
absolutely not process but how long can
that be
i i think they're i honestly think
they'll be pivoting by their november
second beating that's kind of like my my
course pivot in terms of let's pause
or pivot in terms of reverse let's do
interest rates let's go back to loose
monetary policy qe et cetera
no i think uh so pausing in the context
there's really no pausing in
quantitative either pausing by no longer
shrinking or expanded balance sheet
that's what i mean by pivot that yeah
that would represent a real pivot um i
don't think pausing and interest rates
while still doing a hundred billion
dollars or 90 some billion dollars a qe
two t's who
cares we don't care about the interest
rates anymore they're already been
priced in maybe you'll get another 25 to
35 basis points higher in the terminal
funds rate expectations if inflation
over the next month or two surprises to
the upside which it very much can by the
way we can go into all the wonky details
on why i think that they it might but in
in terms of the pause and the pivot i do
believe that hey if the fed gets to the
november 2nd meeting the world is
sufficiently on fire from the capital
markets perspective going back to that
first chart you've seen a more
substantial tightening of financial
conditions associated with a more
significant growth slowdown that we have
projected particularly throughout the
summer months then i do believe they'll
be able to say hey
i think uh 95 billion was too much let's
just turn this off and look around and
see and see where inflation settles out
if they pause by just saying hey we're
going to go from 95 billion to 50
billion and we're not hiking interest
rates anymore then all bets are off but
i think once they once they pause what
what constitute a pause in my book is
they stop this entire program altogether
they don't have to go to qe but they
have to stop quantitative type
which they haven't even started by the
way it starts next wednesday
any thoughts on uh
whether they will get an interest rate
cut that that's my
contrary this only contributor i thought
i think i have right now is that we may
get a i call it an interest rate
like uh cut check where everyone is
thinking one thing and they basically
just give us that one cut to say hey
continue the party
no see see i i i see this is this is
goes to the behavioral side of the trade
which is equally as important in times
like these so uh for all of you watching
and listening
my favorite book and i'm sure i'll give
the actual what books do i read and what
what not thinking fast and slow by danny
kahneman aimless deversky is arguably
the most important book you'll ever read
if you want to think about finance and
economics um certainly my favorite book
and you know i highly recommend everyone
read that book in terms of understanding
the behavioral side of this we're human
beings and you have to realize that the
fantasy movies danny ellen's a human
being j pals a human being joe biden
human being these three human beings got
together on tuesday just to remind the
american public that hey even though
when you go to the grocery store it
keeps going up and up and you go to a
gas pump it keeps going up and up and
you you take your kids school shopping
and prices keep going up and up and up
you try to take your wife out for dinner
it keeps going up and up and up hey
we're gonna do something about it we
messed up my bad we got transitory wrong
i mean did you hear yelling and bullet
yesterday i mean buller basically came
out and said look
we're going to lose our credibility if
we don't get going and yelling was like
yeah you're right i got this i got the
damn call wrong do you think they got it
wrong or do you think that they uh knew
what was gonna happen and didn't say it
no they got it wrong they definitely got
it wrong for sure that's what i think as
well there's a lot of people who are
very mad yesterday when i said that we
should respect the fact that a public
official like janet yellen was willing
to say on national television i got it
wrong i thought that was fantastic and
we should encourage more public
officials there's an excuse that they
got it wrong doesn't mean that we should
listen next time but
admitting that you're wrong in public
one very hard for those people to do and
we should celebrate when uh when they do
it at a minimum or at least encourage
other people to do it yeah absolutely so
there's a bit i can count on one hand of
all the investors um that i could that i
know got the inflation call right
certainly uh jim bianco uh julian
brigdon uh maybe there's a couple others
that i'm forgetting i apologize for
getting you here but i'll be the first
person to say we we got it wrong goldman
sachs got it wrong pimko got it wrong
the fed got it wrong
you know all these institutions and
research shops and very important wall
street institutions and not so important
institutions sitting in my uh home here
all got the inflation call wrong just to
varying degrees right so to be honest
here these are human beings with models
and forecasts and it's hard to model the
kinds of shocks that we've experienced
particularly in the second half of the
wave the you know the kind of the
omicron dynamics shutting down the
global economy again and the supply
chain absorptions that came out of that
the russian eurasian of ukraine and the
additional supply chain pressure on
things like energy and food prices that
stuff that stuff's hard to model it's
easy to model the core inflation
dynamics that stuff it's been pretty
simple but the other stuff has been very
difficult but that's neither here nor
there what i'm really trying to say is
this is an institution the federal
reserve that is hell-bent on regaining
credibility from getting a call wrong
they're a wounded animal and right now
they're fighting two battles one getting
inflation back towards its target
and two regaining the trust of the
american people that they're there you
know millions are being harmed by uh
these very aggressive uh price rises so
uh i would argue uh pomp we're more
likely to see them get incrementally
hawkish relative to what's priced in the
financial markets particularly you know
fed fund futures euro dollar futures ois
et cetera than they are to get
incrementally dovish at least over the
next few months
the other thing that i've seen recently
is arthur hayes uh former bit mex ceo uh
he wrote a report and he said he
essentially called the bottom right not
explicitly hey this is the exact bottom
but he was like look i don't think
bitcoin go below 25 27 000. i think e he
was like about like 1700 1800 somewhere
in that range and he used three things
uh as his argument one was there was a
decoupling uh to some degree of crypto
from the nasdaq 100 uh two was like the
media is just yelling and screaming and
being absurd and saying it's all dead
and everyone in the industry is you know
idiotic um and then uh the third thing
he said oh was a relationship uh to pass
cycles so you know the price in a news
cycle doesn't go below the past all-time
high so bitcoin at 20 000 in 2017
unlikely that we would go below that
what's your take on like how bitcoin and
crypto as an industry will will perform
kind of moving forward given all this
macro uh kind of uncertainty
yeah so right now there's a couple
things i'll say on that so um right now
i've been very um you know one thing
that's sort of you know keeping me from
saying this is going to be a sustain
there's several factors that have kept
us from saying this will be a sustained
bear market rally at least in stocks is
the fact that we have not seen the kind
of participation you would expect to see
from the digital asset space obviously
bitcoin's been chopping people up
between 29 and 31 000 for weeks now um
ethereum obviously even looking even
worse from a technical standpoint um but
just if you think about it from a
broader macro market cycle perspective i
mean a lot has to go right
if you see another 20 to 30 percent no
not 23 another 20 decline in the s p
from here let's call it 20 to 30 decline
the nasdaq from here for bitcoin not to
make new lows uh it'll be i think it'll
be very difficult and again don't forget
it's not just about where the
fundamentals or the technicals are
because we know um you know sorry i'm
not great with on chain analytics but
you know we know that you know somewhere
around 22 000 there's a key level
support 24 000 as a key level support
fundamentals don't matter when people
need liquidity and i can guarantee you
if growth slows
worse if the growth slow down by the way
this is our base case scenario if the
growth slowdown is worse in our base
case scenario we do go into a profit
cycle recession and the fed is you know
shrinking its balance sheet at 95
billion a month and inflation is not
behaving
people will demand liquidity they will
demand cash and the only way they're
going to be able to get it is by selling
risk assets because again the deposits
in the banking system are shrinking the
reverse repo uptake continues to go
higher and the fed wants it to go higher
this is this is a significant draining
of liquidity from financial markets that
is about to happen and so in my opinion
i'm not sure you can price that in
because again these are technical
dynamics
what's the thing that you're looking
forward to uh or looking at that would
surprise people the most right now
oh and 100 percent of the inflation uh
surprising to the upside over the next
couple months surprising to the upside
yeah and the reason i say that so right
now um particularly if you look at core
inflation dynamics which is obviously
what the fed cares about most core pce
let's take core pc right now core pc is
running at about four and four point
nine percent no is it yeah five point
nine percent four point nine percent on
a year over year basis three point nine
percent on a three-month annualized
basis and then you take it and look at
what are the driver what are the leading
indicators for core pc it's things like
core services inflation you know core
goods inflation median cpi sticky cpi
etc so let's highlight two of those
factors right now one of those factors
is core good cpi significant slowdown
we're only tracking it 0.8 percent on a
three-month annualized
inflation rate basis yeah that's down
from a 10 year-over-year rate of change
or 10
right now core services inflation is
actually accelerating it's up seven
point five percent on a three month
annualized basis versus right around up
five on a year over year basis so what
the biggest risk i think to financial
markets right now is a
is a incremental repricing higher of
terminal fed funds rate expectations and
incremental hawkish rhetoric surrounding
the pace the timing etc of the
quantitative tightening program and how
you get there is by
services inflation alongside energy
prices continuing to rise and food
prices continuing to rise it's taken
that baton wrestling that baton away
from goods prices and causing the
inflation basket to either flatten out
or start to rise again from a core
inflation standpoint and to me i think
that we'd all be completely you know for
lack of a better word [ __ ] if that
occurs and i think that's a more than
reason that's a more than 33 percent
chance of occurring in the next couple
of months and no one's really positioned
for that
yeah it's um
did we're gonna be talking about this a
long time there's no right answer right
it is inflation is sticky this is what
we learned in the 70s that's what we
learned and kind of in the early parts
of 2000 in 2008 like it's one
inflation's a lagging indicator you
can't just expect inflation to magically
go down by itself without a slowdown in
growth and the production demand and the
easing of supply and demand dynamics but
two it's sticky yeah it permeates it's
sticky you know business a raises prices
and wages go up then business b does the
same thing then business c does with
business b it's it's it's a process and
so we have a lot of tightening to do
ahead of us for inflation to really
start to behave and i think the man or
the fed wants not just because of its
mandate but also because of its you know
very human psychology that need to heal
my friend i appreciate you always coming
here dropping absolute facts on us uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about 42
macro
absolutely man thank you man uh phil
42macro.com come check us out uh we
definitely put out some uh what i think
some world-class research but if you if
you can't afford it uh just go check us
out on twitter at 42 macro uh d dale
d-d-a-l-e appreciate your pump all right
buddy sounds good we'll see you next
week and uh
i'm making my paris uh recommendation
list and i'm gonna call you
i got some
the folks that uh the folks at the the
aquarium club know me very well
all right buddy i'll see you later